partenza brutta per i ragazzi prevede
che sono video sono parigi oggi siamo su
un nuovo format negata in formato
l'abbiamo riportato sul canale e è
veramente figo
c'è un unboxing fatto molto meglio
perché ogni puntata avrà una scatola
diversa con un tema diverso io non so
che cosa sto per andare al di scatolare
e lo vediamo insieme in ogni puntata
quindi oggi iniziamo con il primo pacco
premessa uso la parola parco però non vi
scandalizzate lo faccio sempre l'ex co
magari lo facciamo comparire in una
maniera un po più normale
vabbè allora come potete vedere il pacco
anche l'adesivo a un box in famiglia ei
cinque milioni di iscritti ragazzo io
direi che possiamo iniziare forbici
partiamo va bene ed ha un sacco di tempo
ragazzi che non faccio più questa cosa
quindi ho perso quasi la mia skilled
adescato latore troppo lento o
decisamente persone skilled adescato
latore dovessi provare a indovinare il
tema non lo so però per me il regalo da
questo anno allora
ok per essere la prima puntata
siamo andati già sulle cose strane e non
pensavo fosse così maledizione allora la
prima cosa che tiriamo fuori da questo
palco sono delle patatine wasabi ma è
quindi tutta roba giapponese il vero va
giapponesi ma è veramente troppo
giapponese va bene allora direi di
iniziare con la prima puntata di cibi
giapponesi cibi schifo c'è cv in robe
che ti fanno ingrassare la prima cosa
che andiamo a provare oggi sono le
patatine al wasabi nora gaiola sabino
all'orecchio sicuri di fare questa cosa
manca poco a pranzo
[Musica]
donna sono buonissimi buone problema era
il retrogusto no ho bisogno di un ora
non c'è ormai non ne andrà mai sono
piccantissime vabbè sono buonissime se
non fosse per la roba che ti lascio io
non lo reggo il piccante lega tutto però
sono veramente buona ness
allora andiamo su una roba un po strana
come se non ce ne fossero biglietti
allora sentite essendo giapponesi non
capisco che cosa sia sembrano olive però
effettivamente non si capisce assaggiamo
devo proprio perché in giappone vendono
le olive dentro la busta perché abbiamo
riportato format nel 2018 mannaia sa di
escrementi
[Musica]
fa veramente vomitare questi casi sono
stabili un sacco prossimo prossimo non
ho idea di che cosa fosse ragazzi era
tipo né roba mix tra un'oliva molto
molto aspra e la cosa piu schifosa
visibilmente non lo so comunque la mensa
della mia scuola media era 10 volte
meglio e ho detto tutto
max ma siccome prima abbiamo mangiato
delle cose che lasciano abbastanza
schifo queste mi sembrano abbastanza
buona cioè non mi sembra roba vivibile
allora kameda 6 cache l'inps flavoured
risk brecker
credo che siano dei cracker al riso
aromatizzati al gambero stream
questo dovrebbe riprendermi lo tengo
quali votare mangia qualcosa di schifoso
non mangio west limited e motori quello
del cibo per cani
giuro incredibile però il sapore spero
sia diverso da questo mondo mi fanno
cagare però riconosco che alcune persone
potrebbero piacere
sappi di gambero morto next questo
bellissimo questo non so cosa sia mi
dispiace anche solo aprirlo è veramente
figo
ho notato adesso perché io le cose ci
arrivò dopo che dietro c'è un etichetta
in inglese in ogni bacio maschi cassi un
po di inglese in teoria dovrei riuscire
a capire la descritto churko alcuni
carbone quello che fai minecraft carbone
album di bambù aromatizzato al pisello e
lo giuro sfiv questo apriamo tutte le
parole che ho letto ma dietro non mi
sono piaciuti questo non possiamo
mettere al pisello blend c'è scritto
billy black pacchetto è bellissimo
penso che più bello sia il pacco più
schifo faccia mila roba perché devono
compensare non quelli buoni sono quelli
nel pacchetto bis keepod troviamo i
piselli non si mangiano nel notifico
devono fare in padella o li magia che
così il mangiare così no perché pizzini
alla salmonella
carino mamma ciao ascolta gli i piselli
e li posso mangiare anche crudi non gli
deve per forza sono quelli no è una roba
strano che mi hanno portato lo sa il
giappone va beh
e vabbè dai 1 sono mangiato uno sì mi
importa dai aveva niente vuole sapere se
morirono prima l'ho fatto per le news
niente ma lascia stare i santi fece voci
il bacino
ciao ti voglio bene la vera gas e la
mamma ha detto che posso mangiare uno e
non mi succede niente prendono piccola
si sa mai che muoia per un picco non ha
odore la cosa e finissima prof
drago è buonissimo questo è buonissimo
203 questo è più buona numero arapaj da
prendere per farci l'aperitivo ragazzo
buonissimo lo consiglio al bar di fianco
sa di tipo le noccioline però dolciastre
buonissimi loro estero come cosa devo
fare qua allora aprire apriamo ma siamo
sicuri di questa cosa pazza acqua
microonde
aspetteremo facendo qualcosa di molto
interessante perfetto stile successivo
va bene siccome è rimasto solido come
solo bagnato però come prima facciamo
che lasciamo in stand by
parliamo poi alla fine vedere se si è
cotto e andiamo provare le altre
prelibatezze le scrivo quindi ragazzi
proseguiamo con la nostra pizza di
prelibatezze giapponesi nel mentre che
si cuoce la pasta allora devo scegliere
la meno peggio tutte quelle che vedo
sono tutte una peggio dell'altra quindi
non so quale questa sembrava carina la
scatola trovato caramel corn e
fighissima la scatola dato a toccare
mccord snack aromatizzato al caramello e
questo non è buono mi uccido
[Musica]
un buonissimo questo è buonissimo dio
benedica il caramello finalmente un
qualcosa di decente l'abbiamo trovato
next allora questo non lo volevo tirare
fuori non perché sono fagioli ma perché
il mio romani fanno paura
se io metto sta roba nella mia credenza
poi apre lo sportello mi di un infarto
ricordatevi che dovete essere sempre al
cento per cento felici come questo tizio
male scatolare il fagiolo
dopo aver mangiato l'uccello è i piselli
orribile perché i cibi giapponesi hanno
tutti un odore orribile tutti oddio
allora non c'è male è un fan sì un po
meno phone si è un po più gérard
depardieu però mi piace un sacco perché
in realtà ha un retrogusto di fagioli ma
in realtà è molto più la consistenza
alfonsi quindi è buono né data buono
pensavo facesse schifo come buono allora
no sia with steam lo stesso non lo
google perché tralicci di mare
stagionate alghe a il plancton quindi
avete preso un pesce fantastico
i giapponesi come lo capiscono bene il
cibo la mia vita fa schifo
vabbè ragazzi questo avrei dovuto
scartare la san valentino perché questi
sono anelli per proporre il matrimonio
molto economici snack di patate al
sapore di consumo beh penso che sono
semplicemente patatine molto pronte
veder sito sono patatine perché dovresti
fare una patatina con questa forma
perché telemetria dito è fighissimo se
non ti mangi le dita condiscono a metà
pero di ri schiacciato a h e c che non
c'è più cioè delle ferite di guerra però
buonissimo mazza rega quando sono già
[Musica]
basta perché sono poi un copyright o no
vabbè ai ragazzi che dopo questa
scenetta inutile massimo messa real next
può però l'idea non è male
farei anche le collane della serie le
metti alla gente poi tre bagni chimici
radici allora radheshi lo conosco so per
dragon ball a sono cetrioli piccanti
all'elastico il piccante fasti col
cetriolo ottimo chimici veri uomini
devo andare bene
stavo dicendo che deriva vi si
riconoscono da queste cose però non sono
uscita piena con l'altro creazionista di
cole chimici io non capii giuro non so
come mai la gente si porti dietro queste
robe per mangiarli fanno schifo perché
dovresti mangiate di fanno schifo fanno
veramente schifo next rex attenzione il
prezzo è giusto
una ragazza semplice faccia comicità
molto molto molto schifosa ogni tanto ma
non è dovuto a me è dovuto al fatto che
mangio da schifo allora qual è in
troviamo dei prezzi che sono un tipo di
tipo dei mikado problema è che non hanno
giocato sopra ma sono salati normale se
dovessi e metterlo sotto la si ficca di
tutto quello che ho mangiato finora
forse sono tre ragazzi e con la mia
gioia
direi possiamo aggiungere a luglio che i
piselli al wasabi
allora io l'ho tenuta per ultimo perché
non volevo dire la parola piselli troppo
in uno stesso punto del video poi perché
la busta è veramente bella per le views
ma porca vacca
[Musica]
vabbè ragazzi direi che possiamo quasi
con cui nel video vi sono finito tutta
la roba già che siamo qua lavandino
programma vedere se si sono cotti gli
spaghetti
attenzione attenzione si sono fatti
veramente non avrebbe detto ai ragazzi
questo era il primo unboxing della serie
di fuori di unboxing che andremo fare
come avete visto non c'è più niente
nella scatola abbisogna città finire
tutto in una cosa veramente strano
ricordatevi che in ogni puntata ne
uscirà una settimana quindi preparatevi
che un giorno alla settimana ci sarà
sempre un unboxing verranno de scatolate
cose diverse qui non saranno per forza
cibi ci saranno anche oggetti strani
giochi cose molto la prima puntata
era il cibo giapponese licola trio ogni
puntata non so che lo sto andando ad e
scatolare tipo oggi non sapevo che
sarebbero state queste cose ho scoperto
quando a per lo scafo 15 vediamo
settimana prossima con il prossimo
unboxing lasciate un sacco di like
condividete un sacco perché in base a
quanto andrà bene questo video faremo
cosa è sempre più strane quindi fatelo
vedere anche le vostre famiglie anche a
vostro nome
dopo mangiato per prima quindi ragazzi i
problemi sempre scelto cosa in se vi
piace non mi piace anche vari social che
come vi do tutta la descrizione se non
sta con esiti iscrivetevi e non ci
vediamo a un prossimo assaggio da
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma